Hey, whats up guys.
Today we are back with our silicone brain molds
And today is the day we're making gummy brains.
Now you remember in our last project we took silicone and poured it over real cows brains
Then we ripped the molds open, removed the brain, and then we sterilized the mold in a solution of bleach and dish soap for twelve hours.
Today our molds are clean, ready for use, and here's what they look like now.
Now you may be wondering how these molds smell after having cow brains in them, and I'm actually kind of wondering the same thing.
*sniff sniff*
Pleasantly enough, they smell like bleach.
They smell very very clean, and I've actually run a couple of batches of water through here and froze it so that anything that leeched into the silicone as well.
So these should be safe enough for casting, at least safe enough for my purposes.
I also premade a batch of purple and green gummy,
So all we have to do now is throw these things into the microwave to remelt them, pour them into the molds together;
So we can make some kind of purpulish - green gummy zombie brain.
At least that's the idea
Now we wait
Alright, green is good, purple is next
We're going to throw that on for about two minutes.
Oh yeah, purple is nice and molten.
There's still a little bit of a chunk there in the center,
But there's enough heat in the rest of the liquid that it should completely melt that.
Let's just let that sit out for a couple of minutes,
And work on preparing our molds.
If you look closely here, I think that as we were soaking these in the bleach,
i think It actually kind of discolored the silicone.
A little bit, we got purple tendencies on the edges of our mold.
But that shouldn't affect the way our molds turn out.
Now because these molds are so thick, they pretty much themselves together,
And if you look closely, when you push them together, almost all of the cracks and seams seem to line up perfectly, they almost virtually disappear.
and thats a good thing.
I'm just gonna use a little bit of electrical tap around the top here to hold everything together
so that as we pour our syrup
our molds will be gummy-tight
and prevent anything from leaking out
I pretty much use this stuff for everything and
I think about two wraps is all we're gonna need
the cleaner our mold, the cleaner our cast
there we go our mold is ready for pouring
so our green's been sitting out for a few minutes here
and come check this out if you look at the top layer it's actually start to cool
and it forms a little bit of a skin so any of those imperfections that were on the top before we can skim right out of there
and that leaves us with crystal clear gummy
so that can be transferred to my mouth
or the garbage
or where ever else you want
after right there will take the second
cooldown approaching skim the top I
thought now would be the perfect time to
address the suggestion that comes out of
the comments from Samhith Reddy V says
keep melted gummy in a vacuum chamber
and by that Samhith I assume you mean put
melted gummy in the vacuum chamber and
since we have melted gummy and vacuum
right here i'm gonna put the two
together for you right now so use a
couple extra glasses and just took some
samples of are gummy here you can see
it's already starting to harden up a
little bit so I'm interested to see what
effect that will do this is a little bit
colder and more like jelly this is a
little bit more liquid let's put both of
them inside our large glass vacuum
chamber put a lid on and suck it up to
25 microns alright let's do this there
we go got me in a vacuum chamber what to
do
the green one over here is moving just a
little bit got some bubbles rising at the top but it's a lot harder
syrup if I melt these things down a
little bit we might see more bubbling
oh here goes purple did you see that it just
took off like came out of nowhere just see that
erupted there goes again check that out
oh wow you know what I'm just gonna let
it bubble over what the heck why not
look at all the bubbles coming from the
bottom there
the green ones starting to bubble little
bit too so by now I think our gummy has
solidified let's just go ahead and open
it up take it out take a look at it and
look at this that is an interesting pattern
that spray pattern all the side of the
glass very interesting almost looks like
modern art kingofrandom style random happens guys
now be selling this on ebay to the higest bidder just joking I'm going to eat
it instead I love my job
alright two more glasses these are full ones
just came out of the microwave for
another 10 seconds let's put them in the
vacuum chamber and see how they react
wow that is making a royal mess
the purple is everywhere it's completely
covered the bottom of the vacuum chamber
the green going crazy but it's not
frosting like the purple is you see the purple
is just spilling stuff everywhere but the
green all the bubbles are being
extracted out and that's looking really
really good
the purple I think we like lost half of
our mixture all over the place there is foam
everywhere it's like purple bubble bath
now that's all the green I've got so I
can't waste that or it's going to cause great
problems later on so I think at this
point I'm going to turn off the
vacuum chamber what happens when you open it
oh my goodness did you see the color
change there it was kinda like when we
did slime in the vacuum chamber all the
color came back into it
oh wow look down inside there like the
bottom that was all bubbles has now just
turned into a gelatinous blob of
volcanic gummy eruption when I
was watching things in the vacuum
chamber just seems like the bubbles are
like cycling up and down I didn't really seen
them popping too much and if we did get
them to the point of foaming and
frothing they just came out of the glass
and make a mess everywhere
Wow
ok that's cool simultaneously removing
the heat and the bubbles
oh look at that ok we had some success
with that one
ok so this is a little bit of a
different experience using really hot
gummy syrup we got a really nice
reaction the bubble seamed to have come out
that is crystal clear and not only that
the surface is smooth and clear as well
so molten like really hot demonstrated
in a vacuum chamber is great and the cool
thing is he pulled out some of the heat
as well so this is cool down process
brilliant idea
let's pour it here's what I'm thinking
let's pour the green gummy and first and
rotate to mold around in all different
directions to coat the surface of the
mold with green gummy after the green has
solidified we can pour the purple gummy
in when the whole thing set hopefully
we'll get some kind of eerie greenish
purple gummi zombie brain they look
awesome and taste even better all the
gummy solidified to the surface it's
like silicon but you can eat it
the best part that's pretty much it guys
are gummy brains are now completely
poured and we've got gummy green and
gummy purple combining to make some kind
of awesomeness I hope
how do you think our zombie brains gonna
turn out we're gonna find out in the
next video because these things need to
sit in the fridge for 24 hours in order
to firm up properly but until then
thanks for joining for this project
today guys it was cool hanging out with
you i'll be looking for you in the next
video. My gloves are so sticky
I think I'm gonna take them off